possiamo fare meglio
[Musica]
a
ma
no
ma basta cos'era questa cosa santo iddio
come si gira ciao
iscrivetevi che è bello che sia per
quanto riguarda la stazza noi formiamo
una bella scaletta alla tia sono la
fatica poco sudore può così drammatica
dovremo posso dare il tuo ceca
ciao amici ciao bach i ragazzi ma un
bacio allora visto anch'io ci abbiamo
messo due ore
organizzare questa cazzo di centro non
ha senso è stato alquanto tragico allora
vi faccio questa live per farvi vedere
in che condizioni è la mia casa
con questi due individui è una cosa è
una cosa indecente allora il fatto è che
abbiamo registrato il video che spero
abbiate visto tutti nel caso andate a
vederlo perché è un sia sul mio primo
tour sul loro canale si che sono stati
cascata non riesco a parlare sono
veramente stanchi come se dovessi fare
due pali da uomini che non capisco vabbè
abbiamo fatto due passi leanza ragazze
lo guardate che professionali
ap farebbe esso la partita registravano
un pezzo di balla complimenti sono state
comunque a parte ste cagate qua vi
faccio vedere come è ridotta la casa
d'ora in primis noi non lavato mero ieri
a ieri ha pure lavato e ridotta così ha
lavorato si sarebbe bello per questa hai
presente residenti vo essere attaccati o
di avere la stessa cosa
quell'anno yogurt questo nello yogurt
abbiamo tentato di mangiare dello yogurt
ma la finito marco euro
questo è la nell'armadio non è l'armadio
divano purtroppo però questo è il letto
quello eletto questo e l'immondizia
niente insomma è molto l'immondizia dica
dove raccontare questa questa bella cosa
sta passando quale non fai un favore
alla renzis abbiamo meno un porta la
casa sua
abbiamo preso le buste della spazzatura
noi non sapevamo che fanno arrivare le
cose funzionassero mai e sembra del sud
per ore sulle star buste nucifora nato
ma facciamo ben 81 chilometri a piedi
con la busta la busta e sfortuna nelle
braccia di tutti ma non bastano questa
famosi ma le faceva un po male avete
tanto di video on 19 12 noi non andiamo
avanti
marco dai ok siamo mai indietro sono
lenti ha detto bene mettiamo l'acqua
arriva lorenzo ti senti non è insomma un
piccolo problemino ma da dove dove sono
quelli che sentite la spazzatura è no
ogni passo ne ha uno a c'è io c'è la
spazzatura interne al palazzo loro
cercavano il bidone fuori quindi hanno
portato a spasso la spazzatura non
sapevano dove buttarla e l'hanno
riportata a casa mia mi avete fatto fare
un giro alla sfida finale cerchi a
milano esce con lo spacciatore ciechi la
ragazza
[Applauso]
non ci sono problemi ragazzi sono
contento di avervi qui in questo allora
visto che in questa lei voleva visto che
in questa volevamo fare un qualcosa di
divertente ho deciso visto che molti di
voi che mi hanno scritto nei commenti
che la mia stazza nei confronti di
quella di marco è veramente ridicola
ecco è far vedere confronto un mio
braccio il tuo braccio
ecco facciamo una cosa che si fa quando
senza nonna o una dignità non ce l'ho
più qual è la sua mano ok perfetto non
era una dichiarazione che comunque
siccome lui è è più grosso di me ho
deciso di provare a fargli indossare un
mio messi già stata la cosa più tragica
della vita e volevo provare a fare in
diretta perché secondo me viene fuori la
roma invece chi sei però tu vai di là
perché non di vedere che cosa devo
prendere problema facendo sarà marco al
9 posto fatto il tuo assistente dove
faremo il sistema s larga mi prendi
subito caro allora di latino di vedere
questo allora questo è il mio armadio ma
sì sì sì sì è un paio che poi
sicuramente potrò rimettere noi dice che
questo sono abbastanza merda per far
vedere presa che con questa rimorchio io
spero no no mai
articolo di critiche ma queste non si sa
cosa va bene ok ci vuole molta
difficoltà mentre
e poi e per favore è questo se ci si
ferma più
questa lei sto per fare una cosa che non
avrei mai pensato di merda c6 marco
allora questa è la citt
ok e non è neanche piccoli infatti pro
infatti due hanno preferito e tra queste
c'è cosa più dura per tutti bene vabbè
marco vieni qua sei pronto ad utilizzare
il tuo canale poco su questi vestiti
nomine imparare gli stabili in cucina
allora oppure come farlo da solo e poi
esce e si da sola e cioè vi prego questa
è la cosa che marco dovrà indossare
prego ma sotto no non c'è sotto non
facciamone un bagno nel mio bagno fai
solo come viva beh è stato alquanto
tragico trovare vestiti per un no perché
presenteremo la magna la usano nei video
usavo armate italiane mercedes trattasi
bravo che presto si va dalla magna il
cappello google per i natanti
vabbè capello che però un pezzo del
penso giovanile della mattina è una
tragedia il fatto che casa mia se
ridotta così guardate che di scasso come
è possibile
cos'è ma cos'è questa roba se mi spieghi
che che ma che che melma è dato sapere
che misura tutto pensa se non avesse
lavato vabbè comunque poi abbiamo
tentato di cucinarsi qualcosa che ha
vissuto due giorni così siamo nuovamente
presso bello è stato bello sono molto
belle ballate la professionalità nel
mettere la consolle ragazzi stata questa
ho preso una cassa di birra e l'ho messa
sopra sotto la console per fare
il ripiano dove appoggiare il telefono
era più dietro
comunque alla fine è stato questo il
modo di 3 milioni di iscritti ragazzi
fanno così mi schifa si fanno così gli
iscritti
a me comunque mentre attendiamo che
marco indossi sta spegnendo la
sospensiva outfit siamo andati in luoghi
e ho fatto un sacco di giri oggi
loro hanno l'aereo alle 6 del mattino me
sono le cure e sono tardi sono così le
otto ragazzi infatti vi auguro buona
cena a tutti che state per mangiare
mangiate prima che marco esca dal buy ma
perché potrei fare potreste non
riuscirci gioco
quindi loro come carter e vis poi vero
che cosa andremo a fare stasera che
marco non lo sa
mentre in bagno faremo questa cosa
questa cosa fare ok bene lui non lo sa
ancora cosa perché non di sola hai messo
la maglietta sotto non ci stava davvero
rendiamo sparsi la cosa sembra uno di
quei buon appetito ragazzi cos'è allora
farò io devo indossare nei video la
dogaia cucinare così sembrano di una
donna è uno sceicco di immensa e
bellissima veramente la cosa più bella
che abbia mai visto
va beh noi stiamo per cucinare ragazzi
dovremmo cenare dovremmo dovremmo cenare
caldissimo aic così ti regalo un milioni
di iscritti sia cina la porta così io
anche per 5.000 euro per cogliere mentre
il papà marino ci cucina la cena con i
giusti indumenti
noi vi ringraziamo per aver visto la
live è stato alquanto triste ma ora
nell'area bravo augurarvi buon appetito
con questa visione fantastica noi
mangiamo per quanto ci sia possibile
ricordate bio è quello che vuole dire
ciao ragazzi lasciato mi piace anche se
questi discrete che ci vediamo un
costruito ben ragazzi mese tipo da
questo video non sono capace